What it do? Yo boy Doc Sweets is
BACK and today we gettin spicy with Dune by
Frank Herbert.
Aight lemme ‘splain somethin real quick.
Like 20,000 years in da future, humanity
dun spread their sh** to other planets run
by hood rich crews called ‘houses’ who
all takin’ their orders from the Emperor.
This whole space-hood run off a
dank herb called Melange, or “spice” on
the streets. See, the only place you can score
spice is up on the planet of Arrakis, where
they aint nothin but a bunch of sandworm-riding
thugz called Fremen. These cats just sittin
on they asses waiting for a legendary savior
called “Lisan-al-Gaib” who gonna turn
Arrakis in to a water filled paradise.
Now there also be a click o’ fine
biddies called Bene Gesserit who strapped
with bangin super powers. Word is they tryin
to breed the first ever male super-dude called
the Kwisatz Haderach- whose powers gonna be
the swoelest of the swoel.
So one day the emperor tell Duke
Leto of House Atreides that he now top dowg
of spice mining on Arrakis. Right before they
bounce over to the planet, the duke’s Bene-
G Jessica puts their son Paul to an old-school
test. And truth is, Paul got a mind WAY beyond
yo erryday thug.
Things ain’t quite what they were
expectin on Arrakis. Turns out the emperor
playin dirty and what he really plottin is
to waste all the playas of House Atriedes.
But instead of comin out and sayin it to their
face, the emperor puts his muscle behind the
homies of House Harkonnen, who been beefin
with the Atriedes fo years.
The Harkonnen’s got an ace in the
hole, though- Duke L’s boy Doc Yeuh. Fool’s
actually a snitch who drops the Duke right
in to Baron Harkonnen’s lap. The Duke try
to take the Baron down with him, but ends
up just icing himself and some other jabronies.
Feelin like a real bitch, Yueh helps Paul
and Jessica bust ass outta there where they
join up with the Fremen on the outside.
Years pass and Paul now known on
the streets as Paul Maud’Dib. Since Paul
been chewin dat spice all day erry day, his
powers been gettin TURNT UP. Along with Paul’s
boss fighting skills and clutch leadership,
the Fremen start thinkin he the legendary
prophet. So M-Deezy rallies up his Fremen
posse to stomp dem Harkonnen scrubs!
But before they roll out, Paul
decide he gonna step up his game. So he takes
a long pull from the water of life. When he
wakes up from a nasty-ass drank nap, his powers
so damn ballin that he can see past, present,
and future like it ain’t no thang. Using
dat sight he find out the emperor dun assembled
a BIG ASS army that he gonna use to put the
hurt on Paul.
So Paul and the Fremen hop up on
they sandworms and wreck erry fool that step
to. Then the emperor try to throw down but
Paul all like “AtreiDEEZ NUTS, son,” snatches
the throne like a boss, and becomes the new
emperor. Thing is, since he can see the future,
he realize he ain’t gonna be able to stop
the bleak ass holy-war ahead of them.
For some bruthas, Dune all bout the planet
Arrakis and ecology- how any
lil hood can transform a planet, and in turn,
be transformed by it. But fo’ this thug
right here, talkin bout my man Paul Atreides
is where it’s at.
First off, the name Atriedes comes
from dat playa Agamemnon from Greek myth.
Cuz like Agamemnon, even though Paul come
from a family that got solid street cred and
fat stacks, his future full o tragedy. Mmm!
See the thing I dig bout Paul is
dat even though he packin some sick powers,
he know he ain’t all dat. Check it-
But that don’t stop people from
ridin his junk 24/7. Even though the Fremen
thinkin Paul tha playa of legend, they don’t
know the truth like he do.
Eventually, Paul realize the
universe ain’t just the big unknown, it’s
da INFITINITE unknown. And Paul pity the fool
who think he, or anyone else, can control
errything.
So if like the Fremen, you bettin
all yo chips on a savior who can’t do no
wrong, you straight trippin. Cuz they ain’t
nobody that can tame the infinite. Nuh-uh.
Even Paul with his “I can see the past,
present, and future” bullsh** can’t do
nothin to stop the world from the mess that
lay ahead.
But peeps gonna do what they do-
worship a savior who they thinkin gonna solve
all their problems. Even Paul’s realest
homies gonna JUMP at the chance to lay their
free will at dat playas feet.
On the real, it ain’t a savior we
should be lookin for to fix our lives. We
gotta use these righteous playas as an inspiration,
nut up, and make dat change ourselves.
But ain’t nothin in yo life gonna
be fixed til you hit dat subscribe button.
Catch you lata. Peace.